[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
un asunto realmente interesante uno de
los mayores retos de la unión europea la
migración lo hemos visto escenificado
hace unos días con el incendio en el
campo de moria en la isla griega de
lesbos para ello me acompañan en este
estudio tres invitados contamos con
luisa corradini corresponsal de la
nación en argentina bienvenida luisa
gráfica contamos también con luz rivas
periodista independiente bienvenido
gracias y contamos también con gabriela
bravo corresponsal de radio cooperativa-
bienvenida a gabriela nos acompaña
también desde bruselas nuestra
corresponsal de radio francia
internacional esther herrera buenos dias
esther
hola buenos días el reto de la migración
a partir de lo sucedido en moria hoy en
primera plana
bueno pues durante años la isla griega
de lesbos ha lidiado con la llegada de
miles de migrantes a sus costas el
incendio que consumió el campo de
refugiados de moria el más grande de
europa fue quizá la chispa que volvió a
encender el problema sin respuesta de la
crisis migratoria para el continente
casi 13.000 migrantes se quedaron sin
refugio y la unión europea aún no sabe
con claridad cómo responder a esta
crisis hoy partimos del caso de moria
para hablar de cómo será la migración en
europa en la etapa de la post pandemia
nos encaminamos irremediablemente hacia
una europa más cerrada los flujos
migratorios antes de trasladar a mis
invitados esta pregunta repasemos
algunas portadas que nos deja la prensa
diario la cual califica en esta portada
al xbox de la isla despellejada donde
refugiados habitantes de la isla y ongs
conviven cada vez más difícilmente el
diario le figaro
europa quiere cambiar las reglas en
materia de emigración por un sistema de
sólida solidaridad a la carta liberación
sobre el derecho de asilo
europa se hunde en la vergüenza
bueno luisa de qué síntoma es todo lo
que hemos visto en el campo de memoria
es síntoma de que es el síntoma de la
incapacidad de europa para hacerle
frente al problema de la inmigración y
esto no es nuevo como lo acabas de decir
hace desde desde 2015 que europa busca
una forma de dar una respuesta
al problema de la inmigración masiva
respetando los principios que no se
respetan los principios internacionales
que terminan por no respetarse jamás
buscando consenso dentro mismo de la
unión europea en un bloque en el cual
naturalmente hay
y pareceres diferentes intereses
políticos diferentes situaciones
internas diferentes en consecuencia de
todas maneras yo yo lo que creo es que
el problema de inmigración es
irresoluble
porque se ha probado absolutamente todo
se han hecho acuerdos con los países de
origen de los inmigrantes se hicieron
acuerdos con el presidente turco erdogán
que fueron más que acuerdos de una
trampa porque en europa quedó atrapada
en ese acuerdo y ahora la unión europea
trata de buscar otras soluciones más
pragmáticas
es muy difícil problema en el recuerdo
que malvivía en casi 13 mil migrantes es
un albergue que estaba preparado para
acoger a dos mil personas
louis esto era una catástrofe previsible
cuanto menos previsible en la cala esto
previsible desde hace mucho tiempo por
un problema de la isla de lesbos ya se
había producido también en algunas
localidades italianas y aparte de lo que
todo lo que ha dicho luisa también hay
que tener en cuenta que todo esto
de dónde viene si la señora merkel la
canciller alemana abrió las puertas a la
emigración lo hizo sin consultar a
ninguno de los vecinos europeos hay que
tener en cuenta esto ella abrió las
puertas pero los los inmigrantes tenían
que venir del este de oriente próximo
atravesando unos países a los que no se
le había consultado después cuando el
problema se produce ya nos toman toma el
papel
merkel el presidente francés y también
bruselas pero desde el origen hay un
problema hay un problema de falta de
consenso dentro incluso de europa y
después tenemos que olvidar que viendo
estas imágenes de lesbos no hay que
olvidar que esto ha engordado a las
mafias de tráfico de personas de seres
humanos es decir es todo un problema
no se puede achacar a nadie pero como
decía luis esto es un problema
irresoluble y sobre todo a nivel
institucional europeo yo creo que es más
fácil aunque parezca inhumano una
solución nacional irresoluble y de hecho
muchas veces
europa lo que he hecho con la isla de
lesbos es
es decir es mirar para otro lado es
dejar nunca he querido tratar lo
realmente seriamente no gabriela
exactamente lo que pasa es que las
fronteras externas de la unión europea
que se encuentran en grecia italia y son
precisamente estos países los que han
sido agobiados con esta inmigración y
con este sistema en que solamente estos
países donde llegan los migrantes tienen
que tratar los expedientes de asilo de
deportación entonces estos países como
grecia italia malta o chipre se ven
completamente desbordados y se sienten
un poco dejados de lado por la unión
europea ya que sobre ellos cae todo el
peso del trámite burocrático pero además
de los dramas humanos porque no son sólo
expedientes son personas son vidas son
niños
también esto causa conflicto con la
propia población de esos países que se
ven enfrentados también a situaciones
como ésta como el incendio pero también
situaciones de insalubridad o de
seguridad vamos a irnos hasta bruselas
porque hace unos días la presidenta de
la comisión la alemana ursula von der
leyen presentó su propuesta de nuevo
pacto migratorio humanitario y eficaz
dijo esther bruselas que contiene ese
nuevo pacto migratorio
si así es la presenta la comisión
europea von der leyen estuvo casi un año
sondeando a todos los países las
capitales para tener una propuesta que
no naciera muerta antes de que empezaran
verdaderamente las discusiones así que
al final optado por limar los aspectos
que podían provocar más tensiones esto
ha acabado por porque se haya acabado
definitivamente por el sistema de cuotas
obligatorias de refugiados hace 5 años
recordemos se propuso un sistema en que
los países europeos tenían que acoger a
los migrantes y refugiados que llegarán
a europa pero fue un sistema que generó
mucha división mucha tensión y para ello
se propone ahora un sistema que le han
llamado de solidaridad flexible que
consiste en que cuando un país tenga una
presión migratoria podrá pedir ayuda al
resto de países europeos éstos podrán
acoger a refugiados o migrantes o bien
se comprometen a agilizar los retornos
de personas que no tienen derechos sino
algo que le han llamado retornos
esponsorizados una medida claramente
dirigida para los países del este como
hungría y polonia que se han negado
hasta ahora cualquier acogida de
refugiados
pues yo os quiero plantear luisa la
propuesta de bruselas es una declaración
de rendición ante los países del este
tan duros con la migración y yo no sería
tan severa yo creo que es un acto de
realpolitik un acto de pragmatismo y no
me sorprende de parte de la presidenta
de la unión europea que es alemana y que
tiene muy buenas relaciones con la
cancillera angela merkel que ha
demostrado
a lo largo de estos
cuatro mandatos en su país que realmente
es capaz de interpretar el aire de el
aire del tiempo como dicen los franceses
en este de manera que efectivamente el
sistema de cuotas no había funcionado y
todo el mundo sabía que no que no iba a
funcionar pero era una cuestión de
principios bueno muy bien si no funcionó
que otra cosa hacemos entonces se trata
de buscar un consenso en el cual los que
pueden reciben inmigrantes porque
quieren porque el frente interno se lo
permite y aquellos que no pueden pagan
bruselas ha dado cuenta les pregunto
luis gabriel a de que no se puede
obligar a los socios a asumir una cuota
se sitúan más en la rendición frente al
este o como nos decía luisa en la
realpolitik en el pragmatismo como lo
valoran este nuevo pacto gabriela me
parece que
bueno me parece que aquí hay algo que es
un poquito peligroso porque la unión
europea cede ante estos países que son
que no desean la inmigración como tú lo
decías es una respuesta pragmática es
decir ellos no van a recibir ya lo
dijeron ni hicimos un pacto no se
respetó entonces vamos a hacer un pacto
que les acomode un poco a ellos pero qué
es lo que pasa
esto pone un poco el cursor va más hacia
la extrema derecha es ese la unión
europea que está un poco avalando a
estos gobiernos populistas dándole la
razón diciendo ok ustedes nos reciben
van a tener que pagar los y ellos estos
gobiernos han dicho no nosotros no
pagaremos no pagaremos todavía no se han
firmado el nuevo pacto de inmigración y
asilo pero ellos ya han puesto el cursor
un poco más hacia la derecha y qué es lo
que pasa para mí por ejemplo en países
como francia donde
ay la extrema derecha discurso
antiinmigración istas se están haciendo
cada vez más fuertes
bueno esto es un poco un dedo para
arriba para estos discursos que nacen en
otros países no hay cuotas al principio
de solidaridad obligatoria y el término
plantea varias dudas y que casi casi es
paradójico cómo se involucra louis en
este principio en el de solidaridad
obligatoria bueno es un chiste de la
tecnocracia de los tecnócratas de
bruselas yo creo que hay otro punto de
vista para para ver el problema en
primer lugar hay que ver por qué los
países del grupo de visegrado es decir
hungría polonia eslovaquia y república
checa- dijeron no hay que tiene en
cuenta un poco en su historia y la
historia de estos países es que
hablando de incluso de hungría invasión
otomana invasión en su tiempo del
imperio o saco imperio romano germánico
invasión de la transilvania después han
estado bajo hitler y después bajo el
estalinismo es decir para ellos
ya no se trata de una cuestión política
para ellos es su cultura su lengua su
tradición su historia es algo que ha
sido su resistencia ha sido asistencia
al nazismo como al comunismo
no se puede comparar la unión europea a
estos regímenes por supuesto para que
entender cuál es el sustrato cultural
que hay en esos países para porque no
solamente el viktor orbán y no todos los
países del grupo de bachillerato tienen
primeros ministros de derechas
aparte hay extrema derecha en andría y
se pueden ver las cosas de héctor punto
de vista también es que precisamente los
países que más ha sido ha sido abierta
comunitaria es muy al multiculturalismo
son los que han creado más extrema
derecha en sus propios países porque
esto es una cosa que en mi opinión se
olvida la izquierda europea es una parte
de la izquierda ha sido reticente a
preocuparse de los problemas comunes de
la gente tanto de la gente más más con
menos medios que son los que van a vivir
con todo ese tipo de problemas después
como vemos en las fotos de parís por
ejemplo y anartz es dado a eso como si
fuera un asunto para el extrema derecho
a la derecha en tiendas de cuenta que
está precisamente en alemania en suecia
en dinamarca en los países más digamos
más generosos donde precisamente ha
subido más la extrema derecha y
precisamente estos países
como cría como en polonia ellos lo que
no quieren es inmigración musulmana hay
que decir las cosas claras porque ellos
atraen tienen inmigración ucraniana
tienen migración eslovaca georgiana
armenia es una cuestión que ellos no
quieren ver en hungría lo que pasa en
francia son algunos barrios referencia
en algunos barrios de suecia ya los
barrios de alemania lo vamos a dejar ahí
pero enseguida se le replican a todo lo
que acaba de comentar mi compañero luís
y además les quiero plantear a toda esta
situación se añade la pandemia y esto lo
vamos a tratar a vuelta de pausa que en
primera plana
[Música]
ah
russo se enfrenta a una segunda ola de
coronavirus y aquí en moscú la principal
preocupación es la posibilidad de un
nuevo confinamiento sobre todo por los
efectos económicos que podría tener
especialmente sobre el consumo según los
últimos datos el consumo en el sector
servicios ha caído en torno a un 14% lo
cual ha provocado disminución en el
nivel de ingresos de hasta el 18 por
ciento en algunos sectores y eso sin
confinamiento también preocupa la
debilidad del rublo respecto al dólar y
el euro hay que recordar que en las
últimas semanas la moneda rusa ha
alcanzado mínimos históricos respecto a
los últimos 4 o 5 años y eso tiene
importantes efectos en la cesta de la
compra puesto que encarece algunos
productos como las frutas muchas de
ellas provienen del extranjero buenas
noticias en todo caso para algunos
productores nacionales el tomate y la
patata que también habían vivido su gran
momento en parte gracias a las sanciones
y especialmente las contra sanciones que
cerraron el paso a algunos productos de
la unión europea
[Música]
la pandemia llegó en un momento en el
que la crisis provocada por las
sanciones económicas re impuestas por el
gobierno de donald trump se hacían mayor
y tenían mayor impacto en el país esto
hacía bastante complicada la importación
de productos extranjeros pero
especialmente la adquisición de estos
productos no locales por parte de la
población para quienes eran carísimos
especialmente porque el real la manera
local se ha evaluado más de un 50 por
ciento en los últimos meses esto se hizo
aún más difícil después de que el líder
supremo de la revolución prohibiera la
importación de todos aquellos productos
que puedan ser producidos en irán esto
con el objetivo de potencializar y
ayudar a la economía local pero tuvo un
inconveniente para los industriales y es
que tenían que importar la materia prima
desde el exterior lo que se hace aún más
complicado no porque estos productos
estén sancionados sino por las
dificultades que las sanciones traen
para hacer transferencias monetarias con
el extranjero y esto se hizo aún más
difícil para importar las medicinas lo
que ha tenido un gran impacto en la
respuesta al 19
[Música]
los patrones de consumo han cambiado en
costa rica a raíz de la pandemia y con
ello algunos productos de importación
han caído drásticamente de acuerdo a las
cifras del banco central el mango el
búnker y el plátano son los principales
perdedores pero en la lista también
destacan materiales como el cemento la
cal el yeso la piedra la arena y arcilla
que son menos demandados en estos meses
en que la actividad de la construcción
ha sido severamente golpeada la gasolina
y el diésel también se importan menos en
2020 si se compara con el mismo período
del año anterior
ello guardaría relación con la drástica
reducción del desplazamiento de las
personas en transporte privado debido a
las restricciones de movilidad ordenadas
por el gobierno basadas en los dígitos
de las placas de los automóviles
particulares algunos artículos
producidos en costa rica también han
visto mermadas sus ventas uno de ellos
es la cerveza la compañía productora de
cerveza nacional más grande del país
reportó que el consumo de la bebida
retrocedió 20 años sólo entre marzo y
abril al inicio del confinamiento hubo
un aumento inusual en la compra
pero luego bajo el consumo los
productores locales lo atribuyen a la
reducción de compra en oficinas ya que
por la pandemia muchos empleados ahora
laboran desde casa
[Música]
descubre las historias de la gente con
nuestros reporteros por todo el planeta
nuestros periodistas van donde ocurre la
nutrición cada semana
reporteros le trae una historia inédita
no se lo pierdan
[Música]
acompáñenos en reporteros en cada semana
por france 24 y france 24 puntocom
seguimos en primera plana el incendio
que consumió el campo de refugiados de
moria en la isla griega de lesbos fue
una chispa ese problema que la unión
europea arrastra desde hace años el
problema de la cuestión de la migración
ahora bruselas plantea un nuevo pacto
por la inmigración y de ello tratamos
hoy en primera plana con mis compañeros
luis rivas gabriela bravo y luisa
corradini comentaba antes de la pausa
louis estaba explicando esa esa
naturaleza de los países del este para
ser tan reacios ahora a la migración no
sé si podemos aportar más factores
históricos o culturales que puedan
explicar esta posición siempre tan
cerrada de países como polonia y hungría
luisa y yo creo que luis tiene toda la
razón del mundo decir cada país y cada
gobierno tienen que hacer frente y
aceptar las realidades políticas
culturales e históricas de una nación
porque en realidad no es la unión
europea quien le va a hacer ganar las
elecciones
emanuel macrón son los franceses de
manera que el presidente francés no
puede darle la espalda a una realidad
política social y cultural
una exigencia de su sociedad si quiere
ganar las elecciones y si quiere seguir
adelante con su propia política o
aplicar sus propios propias ideas y
principios y eso sucede en absolutamente
todos los gobiernos a menos que se trate
de una dictadura absoluta que por suerte
no existe en la unión europea
vamos a volver en este punto a bruselas
porque uno de los ejes de la política
anterior fue el denominado reglamento de
dublín según el cual el primer país de
entrada es responsable de los migrantes
que llegan los países de las fronteras
exterior sur como italia grecia españa
llevan mucho tiempo protestando contra
eso
esther herrera corresponsal como alivia
a bruselas como pretende aliviar
bruselas estos socios del sur que lidian
con la presión migratoria
bueno pues esa es la gran pregunta
porque ursula von der leyen aseguró que
el mecanismo de dublín desaparecía pero
técnicamente no es así porque los
refugiados que llegan a un país deberá
no estar obligados a pedir asilo a ese
país que llegan y esto seguirá
existiendo luego se verá si otros países
los acogen pero hay que tener en cuenta
factores también como la reunificación
familiar muchos quieren de hecho vivir
en alemania así que la presión se
mantendrá si llegan muchos solicitantes
pero la comisión europea confía en que a
como la situación ahora no es la misma
del 2015 y 2016 porque la mayoría son
migrantes económicos que difícilmente te
dan el estatus de refugiado o asilado
por ello espera que con la ayuda de los
países que quieran encargarse de
devolver a estas personas a sus países
la presión migratoria así se reducirá
pero cierto es que los países del flanco
sur seguirán teniendo gran parte de la
responsabilidad
y deberán de nuevo encomendarse a la
ayuda de sus socios pero bruselas confía
que esta vez sí funcione gracias a este
gran test decían mis compañeros hablan
de problema irresoluble la cuestión de
la migración
dentro de kiss irresoluble partamos de
ciertos puntos que a lo mejor sí que
existen en común por ejemplo les
pregunto a aliviar a los socios del sur
como españa como grecia como italia sí
que es un punto de partida donde más o
menos el bloque está de acuerdo gabriela
una gran parte de la unión europea está
de acuerdo en aliviar porque esto
no creo que nadie quiera ver un de nuevo
humor ya o campos de refugiados donde
hayan víctimas fatales niños muertos yo
creo que en eso todo el mundo está de
acuerdo en que no es la imagen que se
quiere mostrar de la acogida de
emigrantes de la unión europea pero
tampoco nadie se quiere hacer cargo
efectivamente porque porque esto implica
también una cierta pérdida política lo
vimos con alemania cuando alemania
recibe a esta gran masa de emigrantes la
fue fue puesta en tela de juicio por sus
electores
angela merkel lo pago con la votación
entonces es un juego entre los
principios morales humanistas que pueda
defender la unión europea
el pragmatismo político que es de
selecciones cada 5 o 6 años y que ellos
deben hacer otro tipo de juego en este
sentido para mí aquí hay una fuerte
contradicción entre respetar que cada
país cada nación lo que quiere cada uno
y actuar en conjunto como lo quiera
le tiene tiene que ser votado por los
franceses como todos los presidentes de
gobierno luego tienen que dar cuentas y
claro conjugar esas dos realidades el
patio interno y la voz en bruselas es
que es imposible a veces no es la
cuadratura del círculo
en la declaración de ponerle sobre el
sur de europa sobre hechos maneras es
una broma también porque decir es pura
teoría pero los países del sur de europa
van a seguir acogiendo a los primeros
que llegan cuando cuando se cerraron la
frontera griega con el pacto de angela
merkel con perdonan con el presidente
turco se cerró muy bien a cambio de
dinero pero se des
la vía marroquí hacia españa es decir
las mafias saben mucho más antelación
qué es lo que van a tomar la edición que
van a tomar los políticos y se adaptan a
ello no sé a decir ahora mismo que hay
un nuevo plan en el que se va a liberar
un poco a los países del sur es
absolutamente falso y otra cosa que me
gustaría decir es que se señala siempre
a los países del grupo de visegrado pero
la hipocresía europea también es algo
muy evidente porque los países que
dijeron que iban a que aceptaban
el reparto al final no lo aceptaron y
francia es uno de los primeros que dijo
vamos a acoger tantos miles no los
aceptó lo que pasa que esto se olvida
con otras dos críticas viene porque
nosotros vimos por ejemplo
los lo sé
los especialistas en inmigración que
fueron a alemania donde donde se hacían
unas mesas para convocar a los
inmigrantes a venir a trabajar a
diferentes países y los franceses decían
no conseguimos candidatos inmigrantes a
venir a francia porque en ese momento
había 10% de desempleo había una crisis
económica grave y entonces por supuesto
todos los inmigrantes querían ir oa
suecia o querían ir a gran bretaña
naturalmente o sino quedarse en alemania
o sea que los los oficiales inmigración
francesa volvieron acá con 40
solicitudes en cuatro días este eso
también es cierto no se puede obligar a
la gente usted va a tal lugar por cárcel
y tocó sus peticiones
que conoce muy bien el reino unido que
le acaba de funcionar estos días en la
prensa británica se cuentan como el
reino unido está manejando opciones muy
muy muy polémicas para las gestiones de
los flujos migratorios e incluso el
procesamiento de solicitantes
una isla de la extensión situada en el
océano atlántico a 6000 km del reino
unido- fletar barcos también se están
barajando opciones muy polémicas
gobierno de bolivia yo creo que eso es
una tendencia general en todo en toda
europa el modelo australiano lo llaman
sí sí exactamente esto es una tendencia
general la gente efectivamente ha hecho
el fantasma y ha creado el fantasma del
inmigrante que viene a deshacer o borrar
nuestra propia identidad
esto yo no estoy segura de que la unión
europea esté en condiciones de
desarrollar políticas que luchen contra
eso puede fijar líneas puede hacer
grandes declaraciones pero esto es un
trabajo de los gobiernos
de cada uno de los 27 países 28
incluidos gran bretaña del continente
europeo pero fijaros qué interesante una
una pista que aportaba antes que me
parece interesante explorar que venía a
decir más o menos bueno hemos
criminalizado el bloque del este pero es
que a europa le viene bien tener ahí al
bloque del este de avanzadilla para
decir miren miren mostrarles y luego que
no hacen las cosas por el bloque del
este la excusa del bloque del este les
viene bien a muchos pues es lo que puede
justificar el supuesto fracaso del plan
del plan europeo de la nueva política
europea no pero yo creo que había que
ser muy realistas con los con los
telespectadores y con con toda la gente
que nos escucha es decir europa ha
cerrado la puerta a la inmigración
económica punto suecia que es la
superpotencia humanitaria ya dijo en el
año pasado no podemos más acabó nuestra
solidaria no da más de sí ni
económicamente en el punto de vista
cultural alemania todavía le queda un
poco porque cuestiones también
de edad todavía necesitan trabajadores
que incluso puedan bajar el salario
mínimo europeo porque eso les viene muy
bien también para bajar los sueldos
también a los empresarios alemanes pero
países como austria como dinamarca es
decir con gobiernos socialdemócratas en
el caso de recordemos aquella ministra
ecologista sueca que lloraba en directo
diciendo lo sentimos ya no podemos
admitir a más estos los refugiados
políticos es otra cosa nadie nadie ha
dicho no queremos refugiado en políticos
de hecho no no podemos más con
inmigrantes económicos y en el caso de
hungría ha dicho no queremos en el grupo
de visegrado no queremos inmigrantes
musulmanes vamos a volver de nuevo a
bruselas porque dos tercios de los
inmigrantes que llegan a europa no
tienen derecho
de asilo que sea un poco conectando con
lo que decía luis explicado creo esta
semana la comisaria de la unión europea
para la migración y de bruselas
habla de acuerdos con terceros países
esther pero porque deberían funcionar en
el futuro elementos que en el pasado no
lo hicieron
explican le preguntaste porque la
corresponsal pero lógicamente
es retórica la pregunta es tarde 50 años
así es la comisión europea insiste en
que que primordialmente haya retornos
voluntarios es decir que en la propia
persona acceda a marcharse porque ve que
no tiene el estatus de refugiado el
próximo año bruselas presentará su
estrategia sobre este tipo de retornos
la comisión europea quiere seguir
afianzando los acuerdos que ya tiene con
24 países estos acuerdos de retorno pero
para los que quieran adherirse
bruselas propone facilidades por ejemplo
en cuestión de visados o que hace y así
acepten acuerdos muy amplios en que
también esté incluido esta cuestión de
los retornos también propone ayuda al
desarrollo el instrumento de áfrica que
se creó hace cinco años para mejorar la
vida de estos países y mantener
incentivos para que los jóvenes no
decidan dejar sus países estiman darse a
europa otra de las posibilidades es
mejorar la relación con terceros países
y que éstos finalmente pues accedan que
lo mejor es aceptar a sus propios
ciudadanos no será fácil porque pero la
comisión europea confía en que si
funciona en que sí que funcionará esta
vez
ahora si el problema de fondo es la
desigualdad y eso seguirá y no no va a
desaparecer aunque hay acuerdos con
terceros países pues muchas gracias
estela herrera desde bruselas me quedan
unos segundos no sé si quieren poner una
frase de sujeto verbo y predicado porque
vamos a cerrar ya nos encaminamos hacia
años quizá lustros de políticas
restrictivas en europa una europa más
cerrada el mundo gabriela me parece que
sí me parece que también esta crisis de
la pandemia hizo que los países se
cerraran que volvieran a pensar en sus
fronteras es decir con esta epidemia nos
replegamos todos hacia adentro y esto
tiene repercusiones también en las
políticas migratorias me quedo sin
tiempo para más lo siento muchísimo
muchísimas gracias ha sido muy
ilustrativo contar con ustedes para
explicar todo este gran problema que
comentaban de muy difícil solución quizá
sin solución de la emigración en europa
a todos ustedes hasta la próxima semana
que en primera plana
ah
[Música]